while the first receiver is finally off
the board at pick number 12 the raiders
address a position of serious need by
taking the fastest guy
at the wide out position henry ruggs the
third from alabama the
pick of the oakland raiders with number
12 overall selection and it does justice
to the memory of al davis taking the
speed receiver and remember it was
earlier this week on the pft pm podcast
that rux said he has heard constantly
from the raiders the broncos and the
49ers in advance of the draft and we
were getting into range for
the 49ers potentially taking number 13.
the broncos at number 15 but the raiders
kept that from happening they make henry
rugs iii the first receiver and there
will be plenty of expectations for a guy
who can run very fast as we've seen over
the years just because you run the
40-yard dash of the combine in one of
the quickest times over the course of a
generation it does not mean you're going
to be a great nfl player indeed most of
the guys who run really fast at the
combine end up being busts and wideout
we'll see if that's what happens to
henry runs the third
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports